coches quemados y edificios calcinados
un inquietante calma ha vuelto a las
calles de almaty la principal ciudad de
kazajistán tras la represión del
gobierno contra los participantes en las
protestas con el humo aún saliendo de
las oficinas las fuerzas de seguridad-
casacas patrullan las calles junto a las
tropas rusas las instrucciones del
presidente disparan a matar si es
necesario kashin tokáyev calificó a los
manifestantes de bandidos influenciados
por potencias extranjeras en redes
sociales dijo que estaba en marcha una
operación antiterrorista para
restablecer la ley y el orden los
residentes de la ciudad siguen divididos
sobre las posturas del gobierno aquí
creo que el estado les dará algunas
concesiones alguna ayuda porque nuestra
gente vive una vida pobre
esto no empezó hoy y no terminará hoy si
nuestro respetado presidente no toma las
decisiones correctas las protestas
comenzaron por el alza de los precios
del combustible y se extendieron
rápidamente por toda la nación la
frustración por el autoritarismo es
generalizada así como las malas
condiciones de vida a pesar de los
abundantes recursos naturales de
kazajistán
ante las mayores protestas desde la
independencia de moscú hace tres décadas
el presidente toca le pidió ayuda al
kremlin más de 70 aviones militares
rusos han llegado desde el jueves las
tropas rusas se retomaron el control del
aeropuerto y se cree que han ayudado a
las fuerzas de seguridad kazajas a
sofocar la revuelta pero con las
comunicaciones cortadas o bloqueadas en
gran medida en todo el país la represión
permanece tras un espeso velo de
incertidumbre